joining us now live just outside of
johnny max and victoria he was really no
stranger to that place right
yeah denise we're told this bar and
restaurant used to be a frequent stop
for senator reid whenever he was back in
town the news of his loss is hitting
hard for those who admired him
the henderson community is remembering
senator harry reid a small town boy who
went to school right in the area there
was always a little buzz that he was
coming in and everybody looked forward
to it and he shook everybody's hand he
was very nice owner of johnny mac's john
mcinty says that buzz was to see one of
their own rise up and become a powerful
leader in politics but still remembering
his henderson roots henderson used to be
a small town like not very long ago and
to see a guy come out of a small town
and be so successful is huge for a place
like henderson senator harry reid
started his career as an attorney for
the city of henderson before stepping
into the political world all while
helping southern nevada grow
he watched henderson go from
a railroad stop on the way to hoover dam
to a thriving metropolis that's
interesting you know we
we actually came out tonight because we
heard the harry reid died and we all
just kind of texted each other and said
you know what let's go even though i
know harry reid would drink but we do we
wanted to celebrate his life a little
bit
and we didn't know that until you just
said that that he would come to this bar
that's uh
you know to harry
cheering to a man whose name will
forever be a part of nevada's history
nevada and america is better because
harry reid served us
definitely a sad day for many who looked
up to him as a role model and a leader
for our area reporting from henderson
tonight victoria saha live local now